Whoooo ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une intro mon con
alors comme ça vous voulez du g-g-g-gaming
quelqu’un a dit du gaming?
du gaming du gaming du gaming du gaming *voix horrible*
Oh putain ferme la c'est désagréable
Bon Fortnite par ci
Fortnite par là
Fortnite juste ici
Fortnite juste là
BREF !!!
On a compris il y a du Fortnite partout
Mais nous ce qui nous intéresse
C'est trouver avant tout le monde le petit jeu qui va...
Détruire Fortnite
Eh bah je crois que je l'ai trouvé
C'est faux
Mais on va faire comme si c'était vrai
Il s'appelle TOTALLY ACCURATE BATTLEGROOOoooound
C'est un Battle Royal
Pourquoi les pouces rouges augmentent à vue d'œil ?
Je ne sais pas
Peut être parce qu'on en bouffe beaucoup trop souvent
nan vraiment c'est ceux qui ont fait les premier simulateurs de battle auquel j'avais joué
Bref
c'était très sympa
alors aujourd'hui on joue à leur p****n de battle royal
Et on commence par créer son perso
c'est lui on y va
J'ai pas fait d'game encore mais je crois que ça utilise
La physique ridicule et tant apréciée de landscape studios
Donc ça m'va
Ohhhhh on a un pote!
Yes Yes calme toi calme toi
Je m'souviendrais de toi dans la game si je te croise mon pote t'es mort
La game va commencer on est 49 au lieu de 100
Est-ce-que ça veut dire que le jeu marche pas très bien ?
OUIIII
Ok
Pffff c'est vraiment tout pareil quoi. C'est génial!
Ahh! OH
Ya une map et tout
On va aller au château
WOW!
J'adore
Épic games vous savez quoi copier de ce jeu en tout cas qui vous a vous même copié
On est sur une copy ception c'est bon?
Merde, le château il est où ?
Il m'a pas vu
Je suis à l'abri
Ya une arme !
Il est où le mec ?
Qui est avec sa caisse
Je vais lui tirer dessus, je vais le défoncer
Oh, il est là-bas
Il croit qu'il est seul
CHUT
Discret
Je suis pas mort, je suis pas mort
Nous devons faire preuve de prudence
Oh putain ! Ça tire sévère ! Ça tire sévère
Ohhhh chut discret
Discret, il me verra pas
*Bruit de gens qui rigolent*
Ah j'ai plus de balles!
C'était une blague, j'adore ce que tu fais sur Youtube
Je me suis abonné à ta chaîne
C'est génial tout ce que tu fais
Surtout la fois où tu as contacté des mineures par message privé pour sortir avec elles
C'était vraiment un coup de génie
De ta part bravo !
Tu m'auras pas, tu m'auras pas
On va tourner autour de ce caillou pendant une heure
AHHHHH
Tiens ! Tiens hijo de puta
Non, tu m'auras pas
Tu m'auras pas
Ça va durer toute la vidéo
Ce duel de merde
Oh putain, il en a un autre!
Tu m'as pas
Y'en a un autre, tu vas mourir. Il en a un autre derrière toi
Il va se faire niquer
Il va se faire trancher
AHAHAHA
Alors, ça fait..OH putain
Il m'a suivi
Oh oh! Putain
Tu m'as pas, tu m'as pas j'esquive les balles
Ah putain...
Bon en tout cas c'était une excellente première game
N'est-ce pas ?
Aller on y va
Oh... attend-tend-tend-tend
Oui !!!
Oh vous êtes foutus
Oh la la t'es mort toi
On va se rapprocher on va s'le faire
Alors la cette game elle est pour nous mec !
Pum pudum
Ahh... J'avais pris les lunettes du pro regardez c'qui s'passe
C'est tellement de puissance ça te fais déconnecter du serveur
C'est incroyable
Eh j'me roulotte un peu la moustache
et on peut y aller
t'sais pas qui je suis moi
vous savez pas qui j'suis dans l'e-sport
et moi aussi j'veux un chapeau et une pipe il est trop stylé lui
attends - tends -tends -tends -tends -tends
*click* voilààààà il fallait qu'on soit dumbledore pour gagner
maintenant on y va et on gagne cette partie
leeeeeeet's goooo !
yes ! parfait ! hooo ! parfait ! ho ! parfait ! ho ! parfait
ho une p'tite lunette tiens ! mais mec c'est l'endroit rêvé ici , c'est le paradis !
la vie d'moi si on tue pas un mec dans cette game , je me met en caleçon
pendant mes 4 prochaines vidéos
alors qui tire , on va calmer le game. Hooo !
ho j'lui ai mit une balle !j'vais faire le tour , j'vais l'niquer
t'es mort mon p'tit hijo de puta, t'es foutu
HOOOOO ! HOO !
NOOOOOOOON !! si on tue pas un mec dans cette game je me met en caleçon pendant mes 4 prochaines vidéos
pendant mes 4 prochaines vidéos
4 prochaines vidéos ( au ralenti)
on va la pécho ! on va la pécho !
hooo o o ! oui ! chantez du cyril hanouna ça porte chance regardez !
attends la zone elle est où ? ha elle est pas loin là la zone
ha ça c'est la zone ça ? Ha c'est des murs qui se mettent , la violence !
j'ai un bouclier ?! attends mais c'est pas dégueu ça en vrai pour s'approcher d'un mec
alors cousin c'est baba ! et regarde je t'ai préparé un truc de fou cousin !
*rigole bizarrement*
alors cousiiiin ! haaa ! il fait mal ! alors cousin ! c'est baba ! on va la pécho cette coupe ou pas ?
*rigole* j'suis insupportable
il campe où ce chien ?
Ho il est là bas ! ok y a une battle, y en a un là derrière le
très déçu de cette évenement , heu , décevant , très décevant
aller bamos , n'hésitez pas à être jaloux de mes lunettes ça rentabilisera l'investissement j'me nourris de la jalousie aussi vous le savez bien
y'a un dauphin ! on va aller dire bonjour au dauphin
là regardez il est plus impuissant qu'un poulet au kfc !
Ho bah là il va crever c'est sur , il fait le malin mais il va crever regardez bien
il a écrit , il a écrit il a écrit !
alors qu'est ce que tu veux dire , vas y , j't'écoute
no warpon
haaa ! ok follow me ( c'est écrit mais bon on sait jamais
don't kill me alright ?
i trust you bro
ok let's go ! *rigole*
j'ai recruté un mec c'est génial !
viens ! viens ma p'tite pute, heu ma recrute pardon, viens viens viens viens avec moi
je suis sur qu'il va me tuer dès qu'il aura l'occasion
tiens , tiens tiens tiens , tiens bro
il me trahit pas ! il est trop mignon ! on a fait une alliance ! ho lala c'est génial ! j'me suis fait un copain j'suis content !
et on gambade dans la prairie avec mon ami stylé ! *prend une voie chantante*
ho putain attention ! y a du danger !
mec j'veux pas qu'on meurt steuplé j'veux qu'on finisse la game main dans la main et quand il restera plus que nous deux et ben
on fera comme dans hunger games on se tuera tous les deux
aller viens on y va on y va on y va on a des couilles on va leur montrer qui sont les deux meilleurs amis du monde !
il est là , il est juste la , il est juste là , il est juste là
pouuuuuuillaaaaa ! bien joué poto !
il nous touche ! cours cours mon amour !
putain je vis cette game beaucoup trop au serieux, il est là-bas je l'ai vu courir
attention attention mon pote , attention copain je t'aime mais fais gaffe
tu l'a vu , tu l'a vu tu l'a vu tu a compris où il est tu as compris toi
on y va on y va
*gens qui rigolent*
il est intuable ,il bug c'est un bug
non il est où mon pote ?
il est où ce con ?
j'tai perdu !
Nooon ! Nooon ! j'lai même pas vu mourir !
et tout ces moments qu'on a passé ensemble !
putain alors là ça va chier !
je ferai top 1 pour toi mon pote ! t'inquiète pas fréro on va la pécho cette coupe
mais non mais putain !
j'ai payé ce jeu 4 euros est ce que c'est bon ?
*inspire*
je vais faire une dépression
sur un jeu à 4 euros , tous ensemble !
je vais faire une dépression sur un jeu à 4 euros ( avec plusieurs fois la voix de squeezie)
ouais ! plus fort ! et là-bas de ce côté !
je vais faire une dépression sur un jeu à 4 euros ( avec une voix de mauvaise qualité qui résonne)
ok ! maintenant là haut !
je vais faire une dépression ( voix dégueulasse)
j'vous jure , je suis entrain de devenir un zouave
et ce mot vous l'avez pas entendu depuis très longtemps
c'est normal car il a été supprimer de la langue française Heeeeeeeen !
houuu *fais des bruit avec sa bouche*
*rigole* il est mignon !
c'est là qu'on se sent bien !hein claquer des cul un peu là hein , claquer des cul monsieur !
ho y a un mec au dessus j'l'ai vu heureusement ce jeu est nul et bug
ha bah non c'était un lit
Ho ! Mais c'est une vrai mine d'or tabarnak (avec l'accent québécois )
Hoo !
toi t'es un caca toi mon pote !
houuuu c'est quoi ça ?
Houuuu ! mais mec on va faire top 1 enfin !
*musique irlandaise*
ok
Ho putain
ho putain, ho putain
viens la j'te baise, viens la j'te baise
haaa haaa pardon bro ! grenade ! woooo ! hoooo !
Yes ! pardon j'ai crié !
le mec quitte , hooooo !
*respire fort*
Ho putain !Ho putain il m'a vu !
Ho putain la cheminée elle va m'aider
il est pas aussi bon que moi mon pote
wo wo wo wo wo wo wo
holala ! duel de sniper là !
vas y j'y vais j'y vais j'y vais j'y vais un moment faut y aller mec je stresse on est plus que onze !
j'ai l'impression y a que lui et moi quoi en vrai dans la vie
WHAAT ?
pourquoi moi, pourquoi moi ?
*bruit d'énervement*
je m'en fous je lacherai rien tant qu'il n'y a pas top 1 sur ce jeu auquel personne ne joue squeezie il se nourrit plus ! et son chien non plus !
en tout cas j'trouve y a du progrès par rapport à tout à l'heure
*musique russe*  cette musique m'ambiance, on va faire top 1 en mode russe
*musique russe*
ok go !
alors la mec j'ai tellement bien atterri , regarde ça ! c'est pour moi ça , c'est pour lulu !
c'est qui que t'a voulu comme ça , c'est qui ? fils de merde !
*musique russe continue*
go !
on va être stuffé comme jamais ! gros y'a personne
j'ai plus d'arme que schwarzenegger dans tous les terminator réunis, est ce que c'est  *ne sais pas*
non mec
ho il est pas content
hou hou hou !
mais c'est tellement notre game mon pote !
on va la pécho cette coupe !
on est plus que 12 mon p'tit pote ! et ça ça me fait plaisir !
on s'retrouvera mon con !
le putain de top 1 est à portée de main on est plus que 4 bordel de merde !
ça vise plus mal qu'un putain de chien aveugle ! ça y est on est plus que 3 !
holalalala la pression !
god ... dammit !
Ho putain
*musique stressante*
NOOOOOON !
*souffle fort*
il est trop chaud lui
Ho j'y crois pas !
je n'y crois pas !
well done ! Mais tu devrais me sucer la bite mec ! àl'aide de ton lecteur CD , c'est tout ce que tu devrais faire !
Pardon ! j'suis vulgaire , j'en peux plus ça fait 3 heures que j'suis là, natsu il a pissé là-bas et il a faim et tout
Les amiiiiis , c'etait plutôt simple finalement *rire forcé*
un p'tit bilan de ce jeu il est très sympa , il a été gratuit pendant quelques jours sur steam
donc y'a plein de gens qui l'ont téléchargé il y a 1800 joueurs en ligne
on est loin d'un PUBG ou d'un fortnite mais franchement
c'est vraiment sympa ! et c'est pas du tout simple ! putain je croyais que c'etait simple trololol mais y a des mecs qui ont tryhard
p'tit point faible c'est très mal optimisé et les serveurs sont un peu claqués , des fois t'es déconnecté sans trop de raison
mais franchement c'est sympa pour un p'tit jeu à 4 euros , c'est sympa !
je suis très heureux d'avoir fait top 1 même si *rigole*
c'est honteux  , les connaisseurs auront vu que le mec que j'ai tué c'était le seul kill de ma game et ces gens la je leur répond
et alors ? Et alors ? qu'on soit caché dans un buisson ou pas pendant toute la game le résultat est le même j'ai fais top 1 ! est ce que t'as fais top 1 toi ? bah noooon !
j'vais enfin pouvoir prendre mon chat sous le bras et le nourrir ainsi que l'allaiter
*bruit d'erreur*
ainsi que le faire allaité ! c'est parti bébé on est bon !
aller à bientôt tchoa la famille j'vous aime bisous
ça dégage !
Et voilà bébé !j't'ouvre là-bas !viens , je vais t'ouvrir !
*musique inquiétante*
sous titré par quentin casella et d'autres